das Eis es
schmilzt Wüsten breiten sich
aus die Erde
leidet niemand wird diesen Prozess ab
gewissen Punkt noch aufhalten können das
heißt wir müssen jetzt handeln die Welt
im Kampf gegen den Klimawandel auch
Konzerne machen große
[Musik]
Versprechen sind netto null Emissionen
bis
2050 die Strategie kompensieren also CO2
dass die Konzerne in die Luft blasen
irgendwo anders auf der Welt einsparen
etwa im brasilianischen
Regenwald ich fühle mich betrogen das
ist das Gefühl das
bleibt dahinter steckt ein
undurchsichtiges System mit dem viele
Geld verdienen wir blicken hinter die
Kulissen wir haben unsere Emissionen
übrigens selbst berechnet glauben sie
dass da jemand
nachfragt nein das kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen habe ich von unseren Kunden
noch nie gehört große Versprechen kaum
Kontrolle wir machen den Test und
entwickeln einen klimaschädlichen
Reiniger gut für Mensch und Natur kann
man ungestraft sagen das ist eigentlich
ein Skandal und 30
screenwashing das Märchen von der
[Musik]
Klimarettung
die ganze Welt ist sich einig beim
Klimaschutz tatsächlich haben alle 197
un Mitgliedsstaaten das Abkommen von
Paris unterzeichnet sie alle bekennen
sich dazu die Erderwärmung auf 1,5° zu
begrenzen dafür den CO2 Ausstoß bis 2030
um 50% und bis 50 auf Null zu senken
nicht nur eine Absichtserklärung es ist
geltendes Recht was aber machen Konzerne
deren Geschäftsmodell auf dem Verbrennen
von Erdöl
[Musik]
basiert Jutta kill ist Expertin für
Klimaschutzprojekte und hat die
Strategien der Mineralölkonzerne
analysiert es gibtar Konzerne die sagen
wir wollen in 2030 2040 2050
klimaneutral sein wollen aber weiterhin
Erdöl fördern Shell z.B total BP
eigentlich alle großen Erdölkonzerne die
dieses Versprechen ausgegeben haben in
Zukunft klimaneutral Erdöl zu
fördern und deshalb macht Shell keine
Tankstellen dicht stattdessen bietet der
Konzern klimaneutrales tanken an so
einfach soll es gehen für 3 Cent pro
Liter getankten Benzin oder Diesel
können wir die CO2 Emissionen
ausgleichen die bei einer Fahrt
entstehen und Shell verspricht noch mehr
shells Ziel sind netto null Emissionen
bis
2050 der Ölkonzern präsentiert sich
modern und
zukunftsgewandt Windräder und Solarparks
als Symbole für die
Energiewende tatsächlich aber sollen
Raffinerien weiterlaufen auch nach 20150
diese Emissionen will Shell mit
waldschutzprojekten ausgleichen eine
gute Idee finden auch andere
Konzernlenker wenn man das vernünftig
reguliert wenn man das vernünftig
steuert wenn man das vernünftig
kontrolliert dann führt das auch zu CO2
Einsparung aber es muss eben sehr gut
gemacht
sein versprechen klimaneutral bis
2050 Klimaschutz ist schick eine
zentrale
Werbebotschaft Mission 2050 null
Emissionen nahzu alle Konzerne setzen
dabei auf die sogenannte
klimakompensation und das funktioniert
so jede Tonne CO2 die ein Unternehmen
verursacht soll durch
Klimaschutzprojekte woanders auf der
Welt ausgeglichen werden z.B indem ein
Wald aufgefforstet oder ein bedrohter
Wald vor dem Abholzen geschützt wird
diesen Ausgleich organisieren
emissionshändler die CO2 Zertifikate
kaufen und
verkaufen ob diese Geschäfte dem Klima
wirklich helfen kontrollieren
Privatunternehmen der Staat hält sich
raus einer der der größten Gründe warum
dieser Zertifikatehandel so interessant
ist ist natürlich der Preis es ist sehr
viel teurer
Produktionsabläufe umzustellen
vielleicht auch weniger zu produzieren
als billig im Vergleich zumindest sehr
billig Emissionsgutschriften einzukaufen
und auch weil diese Gutschriften so
billig sind s sind sie so unglaublich
beliebt doch funktioniert diese Form von
CO2 Ausgleich wirklich das wollen wir
herausfinden und machen ein
[Musik]
Experiment wir gründen ein
Scheinunternehmen als CDF
Reinigungstechnik geben wir vor ein
Reinigungsmittel verkaufen zu wollen
gelingt es uns einen besonders
schädlichen Universalreiniger als
klimafreundlich zu vermarkten als erstes
brauchen wir ein CO2 intensives Rezept
Thomas Fischer von der Deutschen
Umwelthilfe stellt es mit uns
zusammen Rohöl basiert das heißt es
werden fossile Grundmittel zur
Produktion eingesetzt das ist an und für
sich schon eine
Klimabelastung statt CO2 bei der
Produktion zu sparen machen wir das
Gegenteil und mischen neben
Erdölderivaten auch noch Fett hinzu das
schlägt rein in die Klimabilanz das ist
der Klimakiller das sind keine Pflanzen
die in Europa wachsen und das kann
wirklich dazu beitragen dass
dafür tropische Wälder abgeholzt werden
gerade bei der Herstellung ließen sich
die meisten Emissionen vermeiden wir
aber mixen noch jede Menge Alkohol
Duftstoffe und flüssigen Kunststoff
hinzu das alles sieht schon sehr und
dann rcht es auch sieht schon sehr nach
einem reinigungsettel aus als Verpackung
nehmen wir eine dicke Pet Plastikflasche
Fabrik neu im Vergleich zu einer 100%
rezyklatflasche haben wir hier den
doppelten CO2 Fußabdruck das ist alles
andere als umweltfreundlich und deshalb
ist die Verpackung genauso
klimaschädlich wie das Produkt was wir
darin
abfüllen zu guter Letzt brauchen wir
noch einen Markennamen und einen
Werbeslogan
wir nennen unseren Universalreiniger
ecofiel und behaupten er sei gut für
Mensch und Natur ich würde sagen extrem
drei dieser Spruch getreu Motto je
grüner die Werbeslogans desto dreckiger
das Produkt gut für Mensch und Natur
kann man ungestraftt sagen das ist
eigentlich ein Skandal und dre
screenwashing ein dreckiges Produkt und
wir wollen es trotzdem klimaneutral
machen durch den Kauf von CO2
Zertifikaten geht die Rechnung auf als
erstes lassen wir unsere Emissionen von
Wissenschaftlern der TU Berlin berechnen
für eine marktübliche Menge von 2
Millionen Flaschen
ecofel für die Herstellung von den 2
Millionen Reinigern die sie annehmen für
eekofi kommt man auf eine Gesamtemission
von
2986 Tonn pro Jahr das ist dann wirklich
also das sind die Gesamtemissionen des
Lebenswegs des Produkts das heißt da ist
dann die Herstellung mit drin da ist
auch die Abwasserentsorgung am Ende Dr
aber auch die Nutzung von Ihrem Produkt
knapp 3000 Tonn klimaschädliches CO2 das
entspricht etwa dem Jahresausstoß von
rund 2000
Autos wir suchen nach Anbietern von
Emissionsgutschriften es gibt viele
Unternehmen die den Service anbieten sie
versprechen ihren Kunden so das Klima zu
retten eine Bedingung Firmen sollen bei
der Produktion so viel CO2 wie möglich
vermeiden und dann erst kompensieren
wir stoßen auf die Firma Carbon Connect
wer hier Zertifikate kauft bekommt das
Siegel
klimaneutral wir machen aus CO2
Emissionen Wald und was machen sie aus
ihren CO2
Emissionen Carbon Connect sitzt in der
Schweiz nah Zürich wir wollen die CO2
Emissionen unseres universalreinigers
ausgleichen und fragen nach einem
Angebot die Emissionen unseres Reinigers
würden wir gern durch waldschutzprojekte
ausgleichen
wie viele Tonnen benötigen Sie 120
Tonnen zur Erinnerung Wissenschaftler
hatten 3000 Tonnen Emissionen berechnet
wir geben also nur einen Bruchteil an
bekommen wir trotzdem das
klimasiegel die Firma schickt uns ein
Angebot für den Ausgleich von 120 Tonnen
CO2 das Geld soll in ein
waldschutzprojekt in Brasilien fließen
Preis 2400 € das passende Siegel kommen
wir zur Ansicht gleich dazu so würde er
also Aussehen unser angeblich
klimaneutraler
[Musik]
Universalreiniger das ganze System des
privaten Emissionshandels setzt auf
freiwillige Angaben in unserem Versuch
wurden diese bislang nicht kontrolliert
ein großes einfalltstor für Tricksereien
auch in der realen
Wirtschaft im mit Institute in Köln
haben Karsten warnicke und sein Team die
klimaversprechen der großen Konzerne
unter die Lupe
genommen das machen elich fast alle dass
sie nicht ganz ehrlich sind welche
Emissionen gehören eigentlich zu ihn und
wie groß sind diese Emissionen weil sie
natürlich erstmal selber eine
Emissionsbilanz vorlegen und da
verschiedene
Spielräume für sich selber
entdecken Spielräume bei den Angaben der
CO2 Emissionen
beis
Autoindustrie Mercedes sieht sich beim
Klimaschutz als Vorreiter mit besonders
ambitionierten Zielen für uns ist das
Pariser Klimaschutzabkommen mehr als
eine Verpflichtung es ist eine
Überzeugung dafür muss Mercedes bis 2050
klimaneutral werden das heißt konkret
null Emissionen bei Zulieferbetrieben
und Rohstoffen bei
Energielieferanten im Produktion Prozess
selbst inklusive der Anfahrtswege von
Mitarbeitern und beim Auto besonders
entscheidend beim Produkt selbst in der
sogenannten
Nutzungsphase wie viel CO2 ein Auto
insgesamt ausstößt hängt nicht nur vom
Verbrauch ab sondern auch von der
Betriebsdauer Mercedes rechnet selbst
mit einer Gesamtlaufleistung von 200.000
km ist das
realistisch tatsächlich rechnen Behörden
in Europa bei größeren Fahrzeugen mit
250.000 km die USA sogar mit 314
[Musik]
000 Experten haben festgestellt dass
Mercedes seine Fahrzeugemissionen viel
zu gering veranschlagt um
62%. im Schnitt geben die größten
Autobauer ihre Emissionen um 46% zu
niedrig
an auf frontal Nachfrage erklärt
Mercedes Zitat es ist bekannt dass es im
realen Fahrbetrieb regelmäßig zu
Abweichungen zwischen den
zertifizierungswerten und individuellen
straßenwerten
kommt Zürich auf dem Weg zum Sitz der
Firma Carben Connect wir wollen
herausfinden ob unsere Angaben zum
ecofil Universalreiniger überprüft
werden
wir drehen mit verdeckter Kamera als
erstes zeigen wir dem zertifikatehändler
unser
Produkt sehr schön ist der für den
Hausgebrauch unser Haushaltsreiniger
kommt gut an Fragen zu Inhaltsstoffen
und Verpackung stellt er keine können
Sie uns garantieren dass das Geld das
wir für die Zertifikate ausgeben auch
tatsächlich unser CO2
ausgleicht ja das ist auf jeden Fall so
Projekt schützt den Wald in Brasilien
und es ist die lokale Bevölkerung die
davon
profitiert kann man auch ein
saudreckiges Produkt klimaneutral
machen ja klar kann man ich kann alle
Emissionen ausgleichen es sind ja
freiwillige Maßnahmen es ist besser als
wenn man nichts tut wir haben unsere
Emissionen übrigens selbst berechnet
glauben sie dass da jemand kritisch
nachfragt ob die Berechnungen
stimmen nein das kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen habe ich von unseren Kunden
noch nie
gehört unser Eindruck der Schweizer
Zertifikat der Händler will uns vor
allem sein Label verkaufen und ein
Geschäft machen keine Fragen aber ob
unsere Angaben stimmen als wir noch
einmal schriftlich darauf zurückkommen
gibt er keine Antwort sondern schreibt
nur ganz allgemein
Zitat es muss festgehalten werden dass
der Klimawandel weltweit nur effektiv
bekämpft werden kann wenn die Grundregel
gehalten wird erst vermeiden und
reduzieren und dann
kompensieren wenn man eine solche
Aussage macht dann muss man das ja auch
überprüfen natürlich gibt es
unterschiedliche Einschätzung darüber
was eine restemission ist und wie viel
mehr man immer noch hätte vermindern
können aber hier noch nicht einmal zu
prüfen ob überhaupt Emissionen reduziert
worden sind das ist natürlich irgendwie
auch
verantwortungslos
jetzt wollen wir wissen ob die
Klimaschutzprojekte halten was sie
versprechen der Schweizer
zertifikatehändler hat uns Infos
zugesandt mit den Zertifikaten soll ein
Klimaschutzprojekt in Brasilien
finanziert werden ohne dieses Projekt
behaupten die Betreiber in Brasilien
würden innerhalb weniger Jahre 40%
dieses Waldgebietes abgeholzt
werden das Projektgebiet liegt ganz im
Norden Brasiliens im bundesstat para
direkt am
Amazonas wir machen uns auf den Weg es
liegt weit abgelegen mitten im
tropischen Regenwald Straßen gibt es
hier nicht einziger Verkehrsweg ist der
amazonasfluss die Projektbetreiber vor
Ort haben den Einheimischen viel
versprochen um sie vor den Vieh und
palmölkonzernen zu schützen sollen sie
Landrechte bekommen und sie sollen
geschult werden landw so zu betreiben
dass auch sie den Wald nicht
[Musik]
zerstören 16 Stunden Fahrt auf dem
amazonasfluss liegen hinter
[Musik]
uns wir treffen Manuel dos Santos er
lebt seit 20 Jahren mit seiner Familie
am
Flussufer seine Erwartungen an das
Projekt waren
[Musik]
groß
sie sind zu uns ins Dorf gekommen und da
haben sie uns viele Versprechungen
gemacht willst du so einen Landtitel
haben sie gefragt natürlich habe ich
gesagt dann werden wir ihn dir besorgen
sagten sie wir kümmern uns
darum und sie haben uns z Solaranlagen
und noch vieles mehr versprochen aber
nichts davon ist
passiert
auch seine Frau Helena das Silva ist
enttäuscht ich bin traurig weil sie uns
so viel versprochen und nichts davon
erfüllt
haben sie haben uns ihr Wort gegeben und
wir haben ihnen
vertraut und am Ende wurden wir
belogen sie ernähren sich vom Jagen und
Fischen auf ihren kleinen Feld bauen sie
manjokwurzeln an machen daraus
[Musik]
Mehl nachhaltige Landwirtschaft das
müsse ihnen niemand beibringen sagt
Manuel seit Jahrzehnten leben sie von
ihrer Ernte ohne den Wald zu
zerstören das kann nicht wahr sein dass
die Leute behaupten ich würde den Wald
zerstören was wir hier nutzen sind
kleine Flächen auf denen wir anbauen
ganz anders als die großen
Firmen
alle F Jahre bewirtschaften sie ein
neues Feld damit der Wald sich wieder
erholen
kann wir haben schon paranussbäume
gepflanzt Marie bakaba Palmen wir lassen
die Bäume wieder
wachsen Bäume wie dieser hier wenn er
größer wird wird das ein wunderschöner
Baum wir schützen den Wald denn er
spendet uns Schatten ih Abholzen dann
würde es hier unerträglich heiß
[Musik]
werden wir treffen weitere Bewohner am
Flussufer Lauro Viana dos Santos erzählt
die Projektbetreiber hätten auch ihm
Landrechte versprochen dafür hat er ein
Dokument
unterschrieben heute bereut er
es
ich fühle mich betrogen das ist das
Gefühl das bleibt den nachdem ich dieses
Dokument bekommen habe habe ich erfahren
dass es eigentlich um ein
kohlenstoffprojekt geht und dass ein
Unternehmen versucht sich das Gebiet
hier unter den Nagel zu
reißen sie behaupten jetzt das Land
würde ihnen
gehören
die brasilianische Staatsanwaltschaft
hat inzwischen alle Dokumente annulliert
und ermittelt gegen die
Projektbetreiber versuchter Landraub im
brasilianischen Dschungel so lautet der
Vorwurf Sitz der zuständigen Behörde ist
in der nächstgelegenen Stadt 16 Stunden
mit dem Boot
entfernt dort treffen wir Andrea baretto
die im Namen der Dorfbewohner Klage
eingereicht
hat
man kann sagen die Projektbetreiber
eignen sich illegal öffentliches Land
den Wald und die kohlengutschrift an
denn all das hängt
zusammen an den Erlösen habe sich der
Projektbetreiber bereichert ohne seine
Versprechen zu
erfüllen sie behaupten sie unterstützen
die Dorfbewohner durch soziale Projekte
aber in Wahrheit kommt nichts davon der
lokalen Bevölkerung zugut
nach unseren Recherchen braucht der Wald
im Projektgebiet eigentlich gar keinen
Schutz dagegen schreitet die Entwaldung
weiter südlich rapide
voran jeden Tag gehen in Brasilien rund
2000 Fußballfelder Regenwald verloren
weil Viehzüchter palmölkonzerne und
illegale Holzfäller die Flächen roten
jut kill hat das Projekt analysiert und
Karten ausgewertet ihr
Fazit in dem eigentlichen
Projektgebiet hat sich die
entwaltungsrate nicht groß
geändert das heißt das Projekt dort
anzusiedeln wo eigentlich gar kein
entwalungsdruck herrscht bedeutet für
den
Projektbetreiber ohne Aufwand
Emissionsgutschriften zu verkaufen und
Reibach zu
machen Betreiber des Projekts ist eine
Firma namens Amazon forest
mit Sitz im Steuerparadies
gsey mehr als 10 Millionen Zertifikate
hat die Firma diversen Händlern wie
Carbon Connect verkauft die sie an ihre
Kunden
weiterreichen darunter Großkonzerne wie
Siemens Samsung und
Boeing aber auch kleinere Unternehmen
teilweise in öffentlicher Hand wie die
Sparkasse
ausnarbrück die Kölner RheinEnergie oder
als besonders eifriger Kunde die entger
aus
Darmstadt bei den Bürgern wollte der
kommunale Energieversorger offenbar
Punkten und bietet Ökogas an
klimafreundlich durch CO2 Ausgleich auch
aus
Brasilien wir konfrontieren das
Unternehmen mit unseren Recherchen eine
Antwort erhalten wir
nicht Amsterdam hier treffen wir den
Wissenschaftler tes West von der Freien
Universität er hat mit einem
internationalen Forscherteam
waldschutzprojekte in Asien Afrika und
Südamerika ausgewertet die Studie wurde
gerade erst im Science Magazine
veröffentlicht über 90% der
Emissionsgutschriften gleichen gar kein
CO2 aus das heißt der überwiegende Teil
der Zertifikate aus unserer Studie hat
überhaupt gar keinen positiven Effek auf
das
Klima West und sein Team haben unter
wissenschaftlichen Kriterien für
zahlreiche waldschutzprojekte
prognostiziert wie viel Wald zerstört
wird das zeigen die blauen Kurven die
Projektbetreiber das zeigen die roten
Kurven haben die Entwaldung viel zu hoch
angesetzt je höher die Projektbetreiber
die Entwaldung prognostizieren also je
steiler diese Kurve ist umso mehr
Zertifikate können sie verkaufen sie
berufen sich dabei auf
Berechnungsmethoden die das erlauben
denn diese wurden ja von den
zertifizierern genehmigt wenn man sich
diese Standards aber genauer anschaut
sieht man dass sie jeder
wissenschaftlichen Grundlage
ent was sagt die Bundesregierung zu
unseren Recherchen damit konfrontieren
wir den Staatssekretär Stefan Wenzel aus
dem bundeswirtschaft Ministerium er ist
zuständig für das Thema
klimakompensation es gibt leider in
unserer Volkswirtschaft viele
Möglichkeiten Missbrauch zu betreiben
oder auch kriminelle Handlung
vorzunehmen deswegen versucht man
natürlich eben das Regelwerk so zu
machen dass es hinterher
vertrauensfollgenutzt werden kann die
Bundesregierung sieht klimakompensation
als Teil der Lösung und setzt dabei auf
die Kooperation der Unternehmen wir
wollen das private auch investieren in
Klimaschutz wir können das nicht alles
mit öffentlichen Geld machen wir
arbeiten daran dass die Instrumente
deutlich besser werden als die die wir
in der Vergangenheit hatten die eben
teilweise missbräuchlich genutzt wurden
sind sie da wirklich optimistisch dass
das geht da haben auch Kritiker ihre
Zweifel Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel
also
wir haben
aber den ernsten Willen das so zu machen
dass es funktioniert
dass es diesen Willen gibt daran kommen
uns beim klimakongress der deutschen
Industrie große Zweifel von Klimaschutz
ist wenig die Rede stattdessen geht's
ums Geld harsche Kritik an der
Regierungsarbeit vor allem die
Bürokratie nervt die
Wirtschaftsbosse zu wird die deutsche
Industrie die Transformation nicht
schaffen und noch mal wir haben
überhaupt nichts gekonnt wenn wir unsere
CO2 Ziele einhalten aber dabei den die
Stärke dieses Landes als Industrie und
Exportland
verlieren der grüne Wirtschaftsminister
räumt ein dass Klimaschutz nur
funktioniert wenn die Wirtschaft weiter
wächst Klimaschutz wird nur dann
gelingen wenn es mit wirtschaftlicher
Prosperität einhergeht wenn es das nicht
einlösen kann wird das was Deutschland
leisten muss nämlich als
hochindustrielles Land ein Erfolgsmodell
aus der dekarbonisierung zu machen nicht
gelingen mit auf dem Podium der Chef von
Shell in Deutschland ein Interview will
uns Felix Farber nicht geben wir fragen
später schriftlich
nach bis wann will Shell noch Benzin und
Diesel in Deutschland verkaufen wir
machen sowohl denen mit
Verbrennungsmotor ein Angebot und
investieren gleichzeitig in den Ausbau
des ladenetzes ist klimakompensation in
ihren Augen ein geeignetes Mittel um die
Erderwärmung durch das Verbrennen von
Kraftstoff zu
stoppen ihr Anteil an der gesamten Shell
Strategie ist aber eher
[Musik]
nachrangig passt das Geschäftsmodell von
Shell zu dem Ziel die Erderwärmung auf
unter 2° zu begrenzen unsere Strategie
ist darauf ausgerichtet die Energie von
heute zu sichern und gleichzeitig unser
Portfolio zu verändern um mehr CO2 Arme
Energie
bereitzustellen wenig Konkretes zum
Ausstieg aus dem ölbusiness Experten
dagegen fordern ein Kare
Ausstiegsszenario schon für die nächsten
Jahre Kompensation durch Zertifikate
wird nicht reichen nicht alle Konzerne
gehen diesen Weg der deutsche
Energiekonzern uniper investiert
Milliarden um seinen Produktionsprozess
von Gas auf Wasserstoff umzustellen die
Umstrukturierung
der der der Wirtschaft unter
gleichzeitigen Beibehalt des Wohlstands
das ist eigentlich eine eine mega
Aufgabe und gleichzeitig ist auch eine
riesen Chance weil wir können ja im
Prinzip in Europa vorangehen unser
Wirtschaften klimaneutraler zu machen
das ist total attraktiv für die neue
Generation Greenwashing durch
Klimaschutzprojekte so ist unser
Eindruck ist aber eher die Regel als die
Ausnahme und beschäftigt nun auch die
Europäische Union sie will die
Bezeichnung klimaneutral als Werbung für
Produkte künftig verbieten die
Bundesregierung dagegen will daran
festhalten wenn man gleichzeitig
Anstrengung unternimmt
alles was möglich ist zu reduzieren dann
kann man das machen dann würde ich das
auch befürworten aber an der Stelle
sollen eben auch Zertifikate dafür
sorgen dass man hinterher feststellen
kann stimmt das wirklich was dem Kunden
da versprochen
wurde so kann die Wirtschaft
weitermachen wie gehabt und baut den
Handel mit Zertifikaten sogar aus
Volkswagen climate Partner ein neues
Tochterunternehmen vW hat inzwischen
eine eigene Firma gegründet um mit
kompensationsprojekten klimaneutral zu
werden viele Unternehmen haben Interesse
daran selbst Investoren in
Kompensationsprojekte zu werden um sich
so den Zugriff zu
Emissionsgutschriften zu sichern und
vermutlich gleichzeitig eben auch noch
eine neue neue Einkommensquelle zu
schaffen zwei Emissionen im Ausland
ausgleichen was die heimische Wirtschaft
immer häufiger macht ist dem deutschen
Staat nicht erlaubt Deutschland hat
seine eigenen
Klimaschutzvorgaben wir sind un
parisabkommen da haben alle Länder haben
eigene Ziele müssen eigenen Beitrag
leisten und jetzt einfach zu sagen ich
betreibe Klimaschutz irgendwo auf der
Welt in dem Entwicklungsland
pflanzebäume in Südamerika und das wäre
ein äquater Ausgleich dafür dass ich
hier in Europa immer noch fossile
Energieträger verbrenne und fossiles CO2
in die Luft ausstoße das ist einfach
nicht
wahr Deutschland muss bis
2045 allein auf seinem Territorium
klimaneutral werden dafür kann die
Regierung erneuerbare Energie ausbauen
beim Verkehr und Heizen sparen
aufforsten und mohre
vernessen Deutschlands Emissionsbilanz
setzt sich daraus zusammen was
hierzulander an Emissionen eht ST minus
der Emissionen die natürliche senken wie
Wälder und mohre in Deutschland
zusätzlich
speichern das königsmoorr in
Schleswig-Holstein die wiedervernessung
von mohen spart mehr CO2 als jeder neu
gepflanzte
Wald was hier an Emissionen eingespart
wird geht auf die nationale
Klimabilanz doch merkwürdigerweise
nutzen auch Unternehmen das gleiche
Projekt zur CO2 Kompensation
schlesig-holstein verkauft wie auch die
Bundesländer Mecklenburg Vorpommern
Niedersachsen und Brandenburg sogenannte
more Futures Zertifikate die Unternehmen
erwerben können um die eigenen
Emissionen zu
kompensieren zu den Käufern gehört einer
der größten Zementhersteller in
Deutschland die Firma holzim bewirbt
eine betonsorte als
klimaneutral und was sich prozessbedingt
nicht vermeiden lässt wird durch
zertifizierte Umweltprojekte in
Deutschland nachweislich
kompensiert wie funktioniert das
Geschäft mit Zertifikaten vom königsmoh
wir machen wieder den Test mit unserem
Universalreiniger ein Online Rechner
zuerst sollen wir den Energieverbrauch
unserer apfelanlage
und Transportwege
schätzen doch ein Großteil unserer
Emissionen wird gar nicht abgefragt so
kommen wir auf einen winzigen Betrag von
nur
34,6 Tonn
CO2 zur Erinnerung tatsächlich hatten
Experten 3000 Tonn CO2 für unseren
ekofelreiniger
berechnet trotzdem dürfen wir unseren
Universalreiniger sogar mit dem
offiziellen Gütesiegel Klima optimiert
durch Futures
bewerben Anbieter der more Futures ist
die ausgleichsagentur
Schleswig-Holstein laden die Zertifikate
nicht zu Greenwashing ein wir drehen mit
versteckter Kamera und fragen
[Musik]
nach der Zementhersteller holzim
vermarktet eine betonsorte mit ihren
more Futures als klimaneutral ist das
nicht
Verbrauchertäuschung das müssen sie
selbst verantworten wir können ja
niemandem vorschreiben wie er seine
Produkte bewirbt aber ein Produkt kann
niemals klimaneutral sein aber Klima
optimiert das ist okay Klima optimiert
ist auf jeden Fall in Ordnung da kann
jetzt niemand sagen dass sie ihre Kunden
in die Irre
führen aber sie haben uns gar nicht
gefragt ob wir unsere Emissionen zuerst
reduziert
haben das ist nicht unsere Aufgabe und
das ist ja auch das große Problem es
gibt da überhaupt keinen regulierten
Markt
Kompensation hat sich als Ansatz gezeigt
bei dem alle profitieren wollen aber
niemand Verantwortung übernehmen möchte
das zeigt sich auch darin dass etwa die
Anbieter von more Futures ihnen
zugestehen dass Sie Ihre Angaben machen
ohne die dann noch mal zu überprüfen
natürlich hat auch der Anbieter eine
Verantwortung
äh da dafür zu prüfen ob Ihre Angaben
stimmen wir fragen noch einmal
schriftlich nach die ausgleichsagentur
teilt uns mit
Zitat wir kommunizieren aktiv an unsere
Kundinnen dass sie ihr freiwilliges
Engagement über die more Futures
Zertifikate nicht ihren eigenen
Emissionen gegenrechnen
können
holzim will sich von seinem
klimaneutralen Beton verabschieden
schriftlich teilt uns der zemensteller
mit
Zitat wir sehen iche Diskussion zu
Klimaneutralität und Kompensationen sehr
kritisch geführt wird daher haben wir
den Zusatzservice überprüft und
festgestellt dass dieser missverstanden
werden kann insofern werden wir ihn zum
Jahresende
einstellen unser Eindruck nach dieser
Recherche längst nicht alle Unternehmen
betreiben mit Zertifikaten nur
Greenwashing doch viele spielen damit
auf Zeit wollen die fossilen
Energiequellen so lange auspressen bis
der letzte Euro geflossen
ist die Unternehmen müssen jetzt ihre
Prozesse umstellen dass sie in der Lage
sind kurzfristig Emission zu reduzieren
und langfristig bei Null Emission zu
landen und wenn die Unternehmen uns
vorgaukeln dass Sie jetzt handeln ist
aber nicht tun dann ist das ein riesen
Problem und dann ist es auch ein
existenzielles
Problem bei unserem Universalreiniger
hätten wir leicht zwei Drittel der
Emissionen sparen können wir müssten nur
einige Chemikalien weglassen auf andere
Inhaltsstoffe umstellen und bei der
Verpackung auf Recycling
[Musik]
setzen man kann Produkte einsetzen und
Stoffe die umweltfreundlicher
klimafreundlicher sind es kostet aber
mehr Geld und am Ende ist es genau das
was entscheidend ist für viele auf nicht
klimafreundliche Materialien zu
setzen unsere Firma wickeln wir wieder
ab unser klimaschädlicher ekofelreiniger
wird nicht in Serie gehen trotz
günstiger Angebote zur CO2 Kompensation
denn das wäre nichts anderes gewesen als
Green
[Musik]
wasashing